it's a horrible horrible disease with no
cure you don't survive it
it basically eats you from the inside
out you die of multiple organ failure we
weren't very knowledgeable about Ebola
before it suddenly took ahold in in West
Africa to us it was a no-brainer we had
to go and cover it but there was a
slightly tricky conversation that I had
with my wife there was a potential of me
bringing back the disease with me and
then spreading it to my children the
question wasn't so much go or don't go
the question was what do we do when you
get back how do we deal with with you
[Music]
well it took an awful long time to get
there we had to drive something like
seven hours on unmade roads to get to
the epicenter which was the middle of
the three countries Guinea Sierra Leone
and Liberia people are lining the
streets selling bush meat and it was
meant to have been bound by that stage
because the authorities thought push
meat was one of the ways that the virus
was being carried like a pig these are
all remote areas villages no running
water no electricity and certainly no
access to government issued controls
they just had no idea what was really
going on all the strength of the disease
that was in amidst we wanted to see what
the epicenter was like
we've literally just arrived in the area
and we went straight to the isolation
tent so you're calm no aid agencies it
was all local people the camera that we
used would have to be completely
disinfected on leaving the isolation
unit so you can't just drop a camera
into Bleach so we put the camera a
diving housing this is a sort of a big
plastic bag that the camera goes hidden
it you can just about operate it in some
difficulty so we turned up and we
arrived and they immediately said yeah
come in it was like whoa okay it was
such a big buildup getting on all this
kit your Adrenaline's going up enough
enough enough one of the most severe
viruses in the world so they take all
these extreme precautions to try and
stop it spreading I knew that before he
went in there be sick people in there
and I knew it was going to be difficult
but I didn't expect to meet walk-in and
within seconds of walking in there was
someone almost dying in front of us the
first person we saw in the first little
cubicle was a nurse well there's lady
here is one of the nurses she was
bleeding
and all her colleagues were spraying
from a distance look like this trying to
try to keep her steady and away from
them a lot you know a little speck of
blood that just falls on your glove and
you don't see it could mean that they're
also in the same position there was no
way she would have caught it other than
by treating people who were already ill
she was obviously in a lot of pain
disorientated and very very ill the
medical staff were absolute heroes I
mean real heroes because they were doing
it day in day how many times a day it
seemed to be the Ebola story in one
little snapshot everyone in here has
been confirmed as having Ebola it's
known pretty much as the death ward
because once you reach this area the
chances of you surviving narrow very
very much
we followed the body retrieval unit
which I think was possibly one of the
most dangerous jobs in the world at that
time the body retrieval team I mean just
the name itself
we are basically gonna spend the day
collecting the dead
somebody's body's been lying around for
two days before they're retrieved and
not only collecting the dead you
collecting the dead amongst the living
we got to know this team and they said
they'd been doing it for many many
months these people were going in
everyday where people were either dead
or dying and retrieving them and taking
them out from my point of view we were
going in and we were seeing these
incredible things and taking these
incredible images and following this
incredible story but at the same time we
had to be acutely aware that anybody you
touched could be giving you avala
anything you touched could be giving you
Ebola when you throw the camera
[Music]
we heard that there was someone can be
buried that afternoon so he went up
there and had a look the body was buried
by people full protective equipment and
then everything went in with the body
and was buried with it it was really
quite moving to me it was obvious we had
to go back when we came back a month
later it had soared massively there's
much bigger isolation unit
it was really big his friend spray spray
spray spray it had gone from one fairly
small isolation unit at the epicenter to
a whole hospital and there are a lot
more people an awful lot more sick and
dying including children
when we went into the isolation unit
there's a small room where the doctors
and nurses get dressed into their
protective clothing getting kitted up
takes a good 10 15 maybe 20 minutes put
on gloves and then they stick it down
and everything stopped down and sealed
and it's all in this absolutely searing
heat and it's so quite suffocating they
said don't touch the patient's don't
touch the walls don't touch the side
don't touch anything but as soon as you
get in there you realize you're you're
inadvertently leaning against a wall or
putting your hand on a table as we
progressed we went to the confirmed
Ebola patients I thought okay yeah we go
this is it this is this is real this is
quite scary
I remember this little girl lying just
incredibly weak
we've hardly even moved doctor kind of
eased up just to check on her and then
and that was quite emotional here I am
feeling stressed within myself but
here's incredible image of a little girl
who unfortunately died a couple of days
later I remember looking at her and she
kind of turned and I remember these big
eyes staring at the camera and I went oh
my word I can't I can't believe this
this is just so incredibly credibly sad
it is incredibly humid you've got layers
and layers on so no matter what
environment you're going to perspire and
did I pass by oh my word I was sweating
buckets and obviously your stress levels
start building I'm working with a camera
that's an underwater housing so it's
difficult to work out whether you're in
focus or you getting the shot
and so that's adds to the stress my mask
started filling wet with perspiration so
every time I started breathing bubbles
sort of coming in and out of in my mouth
I wasn't getting enough oxygen yeah like
I was being waterboarded yeah that was
signed comfortable I said Alex I'm
struggling once you start panicking a
little bit because you can't breathe
properly
the panic just escalates what I wanted
to do was just grab the mask and rip it
off my face just this one's debris
Alex kindly City go and you go first I
don't think there was any option there I
was going first I handed the camera to
Alex and went through the most painful D
robing process I have ever been through
in my life but there is such a specific
way of addressing that if you get it
wrong it could be fatal
I had the doctor instructing me the
attendant instructing me and I'm
stressed and I my word
did it take forever just just manage to
keep it together because all I wanted to
do was we knew that there must be loads
of areas which weren't being looked
after so we went out to the very very
remote community and we found this
hospital which was virtually empty of
medical staff because they were too
terrified they didn't have equipment and
they weren't being paid one of the first
things we saw was a dead body which had
been just left in the ward roughly about
the same time this pregnant woman turned
up and because she had come from an
abode
and obviously she's going to be giving
birth that means that there's gonna be
blood and body fluids and a really high
risk of passing on Ebola
so they all had to get up and this most
intimate of moments when you're giving
birth everyone had to wear these highly
protective alien space person suits it
soon became apparent that we had better
equipment than the actual nurses had
yeah she was putting on her gloves and
as she put it on it split so she had to
throw it away and put on another one and
it split so we ended up giving her our
gloves this is what they were having to
cope with it was quite difficult birth
as well one of the people who was
helping who was actually one of the
cleaners in the hospital ended up
passing out I think through a
combination of fear and also extreme
heat it was all going on in this one
small room
[Music]
in my way then these workers are
authorizing me
stressful difficult conditions putting
their own knowledge but this time we
have succeeded against all the odds
even if they did survive they face years
and years of being ostracized by
community because there is still so
scared about Ebola coming home should be
a celebration be with your family you've
done a great story I didn't feel that at
all the last place I wanted to be was at
home all our families were were were
very nervous about the possibility of
bringing it back
I couldn't sleep with my wife in the
same bed
I couldn't have contact with my children
when I got back you know the school
asked me not to come to the school I was
finding it very very very difficult to
even had my own children this disease
could have been stopped very early on if
they'd had a bit of help but it only
became important when it started
reaching the shores of Spain America and
Britain then they suddenly realized that
perhaps this was something that wasn't
just a little West African problem that
actually had global impacts
you
[Music]